[Music]
this week's 60 Minutes explores the
potential dangers and possibilities
created by recent dramatic advances in
artificial intelligence the AI Market is
expected to become a more than 42
billion dollar industry this year
according to the company pitch book and
AI like chat GPT can learn or appear to
learn based on the stuff that you feed
into it 60 Minutes correspondent Scott
Pelley was given access to Google's
campus in California and their AI lab in
London to see their new technology and
also meet with the CEO here's a preview
how great a risk is the spread of
disinformation AI will challenge that in
a deeper way the scale of this problem
is going to be much bigger bigger
problems Sundar pichai says with fake
news and fake images
we saw the potential with Google's
experimental AI that creates pictures
out of words this is text in pictures
exactly Eli Collins is a vice president
at Google you can generate a picture of
pretty much most things you imagine I'm
happy to put in a prompt if if you've
got something let's try pink taxi cabs
on Fifth Avenue all right pink taxi cabs
instantly we saw a shade unknown on New
York cabs we will next Collins gave us a
first look at an AI system Google has
not released yet
experimental text to video which
instantly answered or prompt Golden
Retriever with wings oh look at that as
with Google's chatbot Bard this has
safety filters for example it doesn't
create images of people it will be
possible with AI
to create uh you know a video easily
where it could be Scott saying something
or me saying something and we never said
that and it could look accurate but you
know at a societal scale you know can
cause a lot of harm there are deeper
risks people worry about uh you know
which is at some point does Humanity
lose control of the technology it's
developing so those are some of the far
out use cases which we need to think
about as early as possible and get it
right
you can watch Scott pelly's report on
Sunday on 60 Minutes right here on CBS